from Cheshire they're reporting let's go
live to Turkey now bringing our
International correspondence John Sparks
who's joining us from ozman yet near the
border with Syria John just tell us
about the situation where you are
good morning uh I think an absolutely
typical scene here in this city city of
250 000 about a hundred and fifty miles
from the epicenter of the earthquake
we're on one of the main boulevards in
this city it's called mustache here
Boulevard and what has happened here is
that the earthquake has brought down
some buildings others have been left
standing let's go and have we don't want
to get in The Rescuers way here let's
just have a bit of a look here what
they've done is brought in a couple of
diggers they are working on the remains
of an apartment building
they're taking Rubble
out from the side and what some of The
Rescuers told us was that they heard
voices overnight and they think there
may be up to 15 people
in the rubble let's come around again
and have a look I know the sun we are
fighting the sun here a little bit
see trying to
remove rubble from this site very
difficult they've got two diggers now
working here
they think up to 15 people underneath uh
the rubble but what we've got here is a
sort of do-it-yourself collection of of
people city workers we've got members of
the fire department but no specialist
fire and rescue excuse me no Specialists
search and rescue officials they're
doing it themselves and here on the
other side we've got some people with
relatives who were in the building
itself it's very emotional scenes a
little bit earlier
see people here on the sides waiting for
news of loved ones friends who are
inside this building the last time that
they saw them as we move around again
let's have a look
I mean they're working with real speed
now
I think the feeling here is they've got
to do something it's very cold
temperatures Sub-Zero
at night it's very cold still okay we're
just gonna move back we're being asked
to move back a little bit by the
by the organizers here yes understand
thank you
they're doing their best but it's
it is an emergency situation but it's
not being done
by emergency workers
there's people here from the fire
department they're doing the best they
can they don't have the search and
rescue personnel with their specialist
equipment
for example the the heat tracking
equipment that they use to try and
locate people under the rubble so
they're doing the best that they can and
that really is the situation in this
city as a whole
some buildings have been brought down
others haven't but really the local
authorities have been overwhelmed by
this at the moment
John as as we're watching your reporting
we can see that those guys there in the
hard hats seem to be a local Council
officials as you as you mentioned not
Specialists teams at all and um we often
see that after the rubble is cleared
away that people try and move in um with
a more close search but you seem to be
saying that and it seems to be from the
pictures that we're seeing that they're
trying to clear as much of the debris as
possible because the building further
back they believe that they have heard
people who are trapped beneath it just
just describe for us the the area
because you say that that building's
come down and the other buildings nearby
are they still standing
that's right that's right I mean it it
is seemingly random how the earthquake
has
has destroyed some buildings and left
others in seemingly perfect condition
and I mean this site here I'm going to
ask my colleague Olivia to pan back to
the building it's there's an apartment
building
tucked between two others with a very
large
pile of rubble behind it and we are
fighting the Sun a little bit to film
this but
and what they are doing is they are
they've got these two diggers now at
work and they are trying to clear
the rubble the building itself has has
pancaked on itself it's come down it's
collapsed clearly a decision has been
made
that the best thing to do now
is to is to remove as much Rubble as
they can and it is
difficult to see how
any person people trapped underneath
that Rubble could survive for long under
there particularly in these temperatures
it's a difficult situation for them
again they're making they're making
decisions on the best available
information they have they don't have
search and rescue
teams here on site
the
Personnel here in The Red Jackets there
from the local fire department
so they're doing what they can
actually see
I can see one or two search and rescue
people now on site taking a look and
that's that is the first time since
we've been here we've been here for
about an hour
what we were told
from one person was that there were four
people they thought trapped underneath
the rubble we were told by several
others that they were up to 15 they
heard voices overnight
they heard voices
but they haven't been able to to get
those people out and you you know you
can see why I mean
I'm looking at
10 12 meters of
of rubble of slabs of concrete collapsed
in on
themselves it's difficult to see how
anybody would survive
the collapse of a building like this
very very difficult but you know they're
going to try they're here they need help
clearly
and you've got people on the other side
of the street desperate for news I mean
absolutely desperate
there are
people women on the other side crying
as they look on
clearly have friends or loved ones
inside this building and they are
waiting for news and this is the only
thing they can do the only thing they
can do is to come here and and watch
that must be
you know just
indescribably awful feeling
yes John absolutely helpless those
people on the other side of the street
there and you mentioned you've been
there for about an hour I wonder if
you've had a chance to speak to to
anyone over there and and
have they told you uh what's been
happening for the for the past for the
past day
just the briefest of the briefest of of
conversations and we got the immediate
sense that that local officials people
who work for the city here are really
overwhelmed by the situation we have
stopped on the way into the city on one
of the main boulevards it leads to the
Central Square but off the Central
Square we can see other streets where
again some buildings are standing others
have completely collapsed on themselves
so I think
I think it's fair to say that they are
they're really struggling with this
I mean let's take I can ask yeah let's
follow my colleague Olivia here I mean
we can see and
a lot
of Destruction here this is just one one
small part of the city and
they've got diggers here they've got the
equipment they do have the
infrastructure what they don't have is
the specialist Personnel to help them
deal with this and we saw them coming
and we flew in last night we saw search
and rescue teams from the Czech Republic
from the Netherlands from Turkey itself
but they need them here they need them
here quickly